[Applaudissements]
bon allez là alors jérôme commandeur
mettez vos mutuelles et là vous jouez
avec nous chez vous bien sur ces
questions pour un barbecue on joue avec
julien lepers
bon je découvre en même temps 1 à oui
oui oui oui oui oui oui bienvenue
bienvenue dans question franchement ils
sont venus pour ce question - champions
se sépare de q vos questions ah oui
question pour un barbecue très beau film
qui sort demain avec l'immense jérôme
commandeur c'est bien les crises ah oui
les manches que l'acteur serré vous êtes
passionné barbecue vous à jouer contre
ce fait il se fait si on se congratule
ah oui je suis trop cadeaux à gagner
[Rires]
la caméra et en même temps je dis mes
fiches intentionnés course alors
l'encyclopédie a gagné écoutez bien ce
cas doit gagner l'encyclopédie des
boules de l'aisne dans le nombril de
l'homme à travers les siècles
un beau cadeau cadeaux avant un couteau
après ça en famille aux éditions d'abel
michaud oui la belle mère
[Applaudissements]
bonjour tout de suite les thèmes
proposés à cirer que j'ai démarré par
séries pardon se fait alors à vous de
choisir nous avons la chipolata chez les
mayas ou le rôle de la lune écoutez bien
ce rôle de la lune feu dans le film
camping 2 oui la sauce béarnaise sous la
vème république c'est pas facile et
jean-michel merguez sa vie son oeuvre
jean-michel merguez on aime les jeux de
mots et le barbecue en général et si no
theater à prendre s'assurer dans la mer
alors je prends le barbecue au général
si on met dans la merde c'est parfait
rouste un bon choix pour le début
[Applaudissements]
attention pas d'un 10 pour vous qui êtes
chez vous je suis une saucisse longues
et fines d'environ 2 cm de diamètre on
m'appelle aussi godiveau je suis
généralement à base de chair à saucisse
de porc moyennement h et ambitionnera
noyautent boyau naturel ment
l'assaisonnement peu contient vraiment
du thym ou dassault de muscade je suis
je suis voilà je suis pas là par oui
[Applaudissements]
oui je viens je suis en santé en 90 et
que là c'est d'intégrer le top 50 à
tapoter par framboise et des muscles et
le titre comporte des phases culte est
que tant qu'il ya de la bresse est pas
finie ou encore yaya alioum labergue est
parti
[Applaudissements]
c
et
[Musique]
chaque partie j'écris pour a berné
honore mais j'aurais pu l'écrire c'est
une fine tige en métal ou en bois sur
laquelle janvier des morceaux de boeuf
porc volailles cale à poissons de fruits
de mer des c est qu à la brosse à dents
au dessus des braises dessus des
barbecues je suis je suis
[Applaudissements]
bref on remercie l'amicale départ tout
faire de la poste 2220